cette fermeture là elle n'est d'ailleurs
que très peu assumée par emmanuel macron
il faut se souvenir d'où vient
l'engagement de la fermeture
il vient d'un accord politique
électorale entre françois hollande et
les écologistes en 2012 et emmanuel
macron n'a fait que proroger sept
accords politiciens
d'abord c'est un drame pour le
territoire comprendre l'impact très fort
que cela va avoir pour l'alsace et on
peut pas négliger l'impact pour les
alsaciens est ce que je veux dire aussi
c'est que c'est révélateur du fait que
notre pays a abandonné ce qui faisait
son fleuron industriel et le nucléaire
civil est florent une frêle on ne croit
plus en la capacité de production de
notre pays la fermeture du réacteur de
fessenheim va voir quelles conséquences
immédiates de renforcer la production
d'une de nos centrales à charbon c'est
la vérité puisqu'on consomme toujours
autant d'électricité